hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again today
we're gonna be showing off the new
gladiator execution called sleep now
faux fur just gonna be hopping into some
duels hopefully kill a couple people get
the execution off stuff like that so as
always like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational side of rauner while also
doing some gladiator gameplays well the
informational site or foreigner includes
balance changes here all updates patch
notes new events hero leaks all that
good stuff like that guys let's get
started with today's video first game
we're gonna be going up against a PK rep
to pretty low rep for the PK I didn't
catch the dudes overall rep so it could
just be good in general maybe not his
experience of PK hopefully dudes here
cuz last time I played a guy he went afk
so I don't have to stab it again I'm
just gonna do some crazy mix-up struck
do some [ __ ] pull awesome stuff
hopefully its execution give a little
easy bread and butter mix up throw on
the random heavy there caught him with
it
throw another heavy again good I am
perfect we're shot they excuse your
first game just go to sleep my child go
to sleep it's such a good execution I
think when I was using this before I
didn't really like it when I first saw
it but now the more I use it I think
it's cool to be honest - there might be
one of those types of executions to be
honest yeah we're trying to do the same
thing with this PK I wanna see if I
could pull it off again just the
bread-and-butter stuff right and we
throw a heavy out see what's up
good block thought the zones for good
measure
yeah good car break parried almost had
it buried
that's parried feint the zone - a toast
F she caught it good stuff on her though
she's backing up it's not good if I had
more stamina what had that for her
backing up is not a good idea see
sometimes you just want to throw out
that random heavy cuz then it ends up
landing like that good stuff did have me
heavy little close to death they're
about embark damn almost got me killed
furniture round three hopefully we can
three oh the opponent said I could pull
the deflect or something like that
caught her on the heavy I noticed that
she likes the dodge after every time I
do that so I just might as well just
whip a heavy out quick easy kill there
good fight highwayman
alright it's going to game to it that
one garden - game - we have a rep one
ARA Musha I don't remember what his
entire like his whole rep was but we'll
see how this goes playing on the
beachhead map honestly one of my
favorite maps to be honest I like then
you a little emote spam boy okay keep it
real keep it tight good if I did I think
this [ __ ] started so I'd like to give it
that little bread and butter fiend oh
look at that
have two health bar down hit it with his
own
[ __ ] thought I had thought he was just
out of stamina for that ended up working
out in his favor pretty well - it sucks
all right super low on health I could
totally chip this away
oh good bee I tried I tried to go for
the bait there of the zone attack tried
to faint is that's exactly what I wanted
was to him to do his full stance and
then I was gonna throw out the heavy to
get the execution but he called it was
impressive usually what I would do there
is I would either feint it into a toast
ever to a light but just because I want
to show up the execution stuff like that
I'm throwing out a lot more heavy than
normal for this gameplay gave me with
that light spam what a beauty
absolutely gonna clap me this whole
round damn is unfortunate unfortunate
gameplay we have your ladies and
gentlemen I got [ __ ] light spammed
did you see what happens in round three
he's probably to do the same at tactics
keeping it you know like this type of
style you know just light spam the meat
till I die we'll figure that out never
was really good against our Musha when
he starts like spamming static guard
glide Eve doesn't really work out too
well I will see how the rest of this
match goes what I have to do is start I
have to start zoning him a lot and get
him that stamina down that's not what
you want to do here but oh I didn't
catch him dude I should just have I
should have went with the heavy I didn't
think about it caught him on that I
actually fell for that but I caught him
on it
Wow I'm actually impressed good stuff
if I had my heart racing a bit there I
didn't mean to hit it when he did the
full block and he hit me when I did my
zone I meant to cancel that into a light
well it managed to work out anyway
because he went he actually committed to
that dashing forward light
not many are musha's do that which is
impressive sometimes tricks them up
what's really great about just [ __ ]
with our musha's is just the the ability
to just [ __ ] around a bit start beating
out their full block since that's one of
their best moves and it's like half
their move stance just are [ __ ] with
it move it she's getting the good old
one-two good know a few touches and it
[ __ ] me over and it [ __ ] him over to
Bobby the same idea now he's garden top
so I can't really go for the top the
side - but Yong it's can go for the
forward - side - still works good fight
I wish I did guy had me a guy head and
down the ropes of it for these few
matches see if we could pull off in Game
three next up for the third game we have
a level 13 pen saying no rep please rep
14 overall so you might be pulling out
some decent mix-ups I suck against Ken
say so we'll see how this goes
I've seen a lot of low levels it's
actually been getting lower every single
match I played it which sucks because I
want to play some higher level people
not that I have a problem with fighting
the low guys good mate it's just I feel
like this game wants me to be balanced
you know it's given that balanced MMR
rating you know that matchmaking it's
not giving me the people that are super
crazy high that I'd usually be seeing in
tools cuz they literally just this
morning before I did my livestream and
whatnot I had I was fighting people that
I rapped 90s in tools and they were like
just as high as me and I'm not getting
anybody anymore
I did the wrong [ __ ] execution good
stuff though did a little faint there
just went for the heavy anyway it's just
trying to get the execution off but I
press why too much because I got a
little hesitant and excited that I
forgot to do the wrong one
[ __ ] yeah but overall definitely do like
this execution one say it's my favorite
but it's definitely up there it's pretty
cool
good guard break deaf we took notice of
my poor health my poor choke my ill and
poor choices to do that move this guy
can actually spam me this guy better not
just continuously spam me with a zone
all game I'll be very annoyed oh the
bait good stuff did he could really
cancel that top heavy pretty late in the
in the move so that's what always throws
me off cuz then I run that time I think
oh [ __ ] alright he's actually gonna go
for it this time and then it doesn't
that doesn't happen I didn't want to
dodge to the side because I'm pretty
sure his whole intention was to for me
to dodge sideways and then for him to
guard break me so I don't I don't want
to give in to that guys don't we catch
on to my moves for Reptar for just a
level 13 Kenzi this guy's actually very
good getting the props on that can't
ever get that zone dude Kent's a zone
non-existent from perry's or blocks I
think I've only blocked this thing once
it's coming yeah it's definitely
becoming a closed or not closed fight
but a very hard fight can't really do
much with my low stamina so I'm gonna
just get a quick heavy real quick make
sure that my get some decent damage but
make sure that my stamina is okay all
right that was close one he screwed up
trying to guard break me and it was just
within that small bit of range where I
couldn't get guard broken so I went for
the guard break out the heavy plate a
little risky there doing the side -
heavy or the side
yeah the side light heavy that was
really stupid side late heavy can I not
speak today beside - light is what I
would say I got really risky doing that
shouldn't have done that but it worked
I'm not gonna [ __ ] about it if it
worked this guy's just pounded me with
some heat right now
she trying to open him up a bit
throughout these zones a bit he dodged a
little bit too early in that move not a
good idea my help my stand was a little
low just gonna chill out of it
just start fishing for Perry's a bit
more I need to start that's what I mean
that's what I need stuff like that
and we'll just do off the execution to
end this don't go to sleep mr. Kent's a
go to sleep it'll all be over soon
good flight did that kid see was pretty
damn good I was throwing shade saying
he's pretty little level and I didn't
want to fight low levels then ended up
clapping me pretty hard for these couple
flights so I'll give them that it's
pretty damn good Ken say if that guy is
going to be the end of the video today I
hope you guys did enjoy that I
personally do like this execution let me
know your thoughts about the execution
itself or if you like that other
characters execution and besides that
question I honestly do like highlander's
execution the most a lot of people ask
me during the stream I think it's really
cool he just heaves them over his
shoulder just whips them forward
yeah and stuff like that let me know in
the comments below what your favorite
execution was be I like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe before you know it cover
the informational side of fauna that
being balanced changes here all updates
patch notes all that good stuff on top
of showing off some gladiator gameplay
my two most recent videos will be on
screen in a bit if you guys want to
check that out went that guy's so
vigorous today thank for watch the video
peace out
[Music]
[Music]